his disapproval rating on inflation is
topping 70 percent his disapproval
rating overall is still in the 50s but
if you compare that to every single
other president at this point in their
first term throughout polling history
this goes all the way back since the
1940s he is the worst on both and the
reason he is the worst overall is
because inflation is eating his
presidency alive at this point
the democratic sharks are circling and
even cnn is putting a fork in biden's
presidency president biden overseas and
reeling from another series of battering
poll numbers on his disastrous handling
of everything the latest survey reveals
only 18 percent of americans want to see
him run and destroy the country a second
time
those numbers have democrats back at
home measuring the drapes outside the
oval office good hair governor gavin
newsom looking pretty comfortable
walking around white house grounds while
the president's away
the liberal leader has been dropping
subtle clues that he's itching to run
for president after running attack ads
against governor ron desantis and urging
floridians to move to california is some
laying out his 2024 vision in a speech
but i do believe education is under
assault
in ways that i've never experienced in
my lifetime i really believe that but
but what's happening now
banning votes
suppressing speech
the othering of our students
teachers
parents
it's alarming
freedom it's under attack in your state
republican leaders they're banning books
making it harder to vote restricting
speech in classrooms even criminalizing
women and doctors
another power hungry democrats trying to
get his name out there by provoking
desantis illinois governor jb pritzker
set to give a keynote speech this
weekend at a fundraiser for florida
democrats but maybe don't count joe out
yet the president looks like he wants a
rematch against donald trump
i'm not predicting but i
i would
i would not be disappointed the one
thing i know about politics in american
politics in particular is
there's no way to uh
predict what's going to happen i'm not
even halfway through my term yet yep and
so there's a lot of room to figure out
what's going to happen
all right judge you've seen the
landscape over the last 24 to 48 hours
what is happening you know i have to
tell you when he said you know you can't
predict this even i can't predict it but
he couldn't predict he was going to win
you know um but but look it it the the
blood is in the water
13 of the people in this country think
it's going in the right direction first
of all i'd like to know what they think
specifically is going in the right
direction but more than that i mean it
makes sense i mean everybody's going to
jump out they know joe's weak they know
kamala can't do or say anything gavin
newsom you know pritzker you know more
power to them it's a democracy this is
america but i gotta tell you man the
democrats are great at turning things
around you know free speech banning
books yeah the books that are being
banned are books where they want to talk
to a five-year-old about how they
identify sexually and showing kids what
you know oral sex is to me that's
banning the right kind of books so you
know it's going to be a
a race it's going to be a culture war
it's not going to be about the facts
it's not going to be about anything
other than the democrats saying that
republicans are the nazis and they're
the freedom fighters when it's just the
opposite yeah because they can't really
run on any policy accomplishments for
all those so they have to go into these
little weird ticky-tack othering
things i don't even what does othering
mean geraldo you know
[Music]
kids look different they have different
sexual preferences they go different
places but let me just say i've been
thinking about this in the context of
something i truly understand myself
i am i'm an old man and i jump on my
boat and i don't jump as far as i used
to i'm not as as uh you know
as skilled as i once was and i look at
biden and i look at trump and i say to
myself these guys are over our
generation is over the boom baby boomers
are over the silent generation is over
it is time for the gavin newsom ron
desantis generation it's their turn it's
gen x is up it's you guys now go out
there and what good ideas do you have to
solve problems you know stop whining if
you're a democrat and backing up that's
the best thing about newsom he's the
only democrat who doesn't feel guilty
about being who he is and i i like that
i like his i like his foul i like
desantis in the same way i mean i don't
like their policies necessarily here or
there but it is the new
generation's turn
times have changed geraldo has passed
the torch i have katie are you are you
ready to run with it sure i'll take it
yeah although i still like geraldo to be
around i think it's good that you're
with us at the table speak for yourself
i appreciate it
so yesterday when i saw gavin newsom
parading around outside with his jacket
off in front of the west wing i just
started laughing because i thought it
was hilarious like so savage to be in
the white house when president biden is
overseas away from washington and there
are ways to go into the white house
discreetly and he made sure that the
people staked out at the west wing saw
him he did the walk around he walked
near the cameras to make sure that
everybody knew that he was there
and he's about to kick biden when he's
down i mean joe biden is the most
unpopular president in the world war ii
post world war ii era he's in a lot of
trouble he can't go anywhere in terms of
his agenda when he says i'm only one
year into my my presidency that's the
point that's how bad it is in just one
year and democrats are looking at this
and saying the time for 2024 is now
president trump has told the new york
magazine that he's probably going to
announce either before or after the
midterms so it's happening other
republicans are doing the same thing so
2024 will be off to the races as soon as
the midterms are over and he's getting
ready for that greg uh newsome had his
blazer off strutting out there with the
sun glass he looked a little fit in the
middle though didn't he
you hate him yeah cause he's uh he's
kind of elegant he's good looking he's
tall
you know and but you can't have a
president that says othering what is
with the democrats in the english
language why are they trying to mutilate
it i mean you know they're they they
want to operate on little kids and
they're doing the same thing to the
language you know uh and then and then
gavin actually visited ron clayne you
know joe's chief of staff and claimed
that they were just talking about
california issues that's like walking in
on your wife and the tennis instructor
in bed and she goes oh we're just doing
post you know lesson stretches
sorry buddy
and the reason why they're not talking
about kamala is that for her to run
she's got to pick a vp and you can a vp
is not supposed to be you know
a vp can't outshine her right every vp
it's like trying to find an opening band
for maroon 5 right oh that's every band
is going to make them look
terrible so she can't so she's toast and
i know i'm not supposed to compare
people to breakfast foods but she is
toast but when you watch what's going on
right now it reminds me of when a really
really rich relative starts you know
maybe in their 80s gets a slight cough
and all of a sudden all these money
grubbing cousins show up and they're
acting like he's already dead and
they're not i keep waiting for somebody
to go up to joe and start measuring him
for a coffin you know they're circling
him like vultures and he's like a lost
gaunt hiker at least you won't know it
yeah i think you know what the thing is
i think he knows we thought he was too
old then maybe the presidency isn't that
important when you have people pull in
the strings you know oh the other on the
other good the other good thing it's
nice for young folks to finally have
their own jimmy carter so when we
reference jimmy carter they go who are
you talking about now they can say you
know joe biden they go oh that malaise
that's right so now they have their own
example they have their own jimmy carter
now so that's good hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now